the sovereign the Ravagers they all want  us dead that's a really bad sign  the guardian happy destroy  get me with your best shot  oh wow I know and almost hit me get  tickets now  the fate of the universe lies in your  shoulders whatever you do  don't push this button I'll repeat back  what I just said oh good  uh-huh okay now here we are a steep one  thug  green means machine a maniac and an  angry little training  [Music]  so we save in the galaxy again all the  world is going to do it  the Guardians cannot protect the galaxy  did anybody have any paint back there I  would have put some paper over the but  nobody has anything that's a really bad  sign this film is not yet rated  [Music]  you